[Music]
pop it out of your sweat there's
different stages of the dab I broke it
down to three stages first stage you
know is a regular dab it and take it
feel good about yourself a little exhale
a little sweat leave that stage to your
pores open up and start sweating
profusely you know where you are you're
little discombobulated in feels a little
you know don't know where you're at I
start tearing up a little bit
Stage two is good now you just go stage
three we just your dad the out just
out sleeping good night we're
professionals
I mean I ain't going on tonight in no
way mom my mom and dad at a
pro you have your doctor here yeah